wow this guy is brilliant 2900 and he
wants to play this increment
there we go okay
let's play c4 one more time
but this guy should be a real star so we
have to be we have to be careful
now we go d4
admitting the mistake
he plays the king's engine we go g3
bishop g2
and he plays this queen a5 line so what
am i supposed to play here
i guess when i was young i was thought
to play e4 queen h5
e5 okay he goes e5 himself
which is a bit strange can i just play
d5 sort of
[Music]
sort of preventing myself from losing
into moose
he takes now both things make sense
okay let's play ee so ed is um
much more double h so black has some
long-term potential with attacking
the king side we're playing like knight
g4 f5 f4
white has ideas
connected to some c4 c5 breakthrough and
then
after the takes we try to promote the d5
phone
the d6 pawn is kind of weak um
after both c takes d5 and ct xd5 but i
think after e takes d5
white has more chances to to attack it
quickly
like sometimes you play 92 94
as a bishop can be developed to like a3
or b4
so you have ideas he plays bishop g4
which is kind of logical
so now we can play queen b3 but the
problem is that after knight d7 will
have to take a pawn just to
just justify all the stuff okay let's
just play each reason
se4 was a threat as well i guess we'll
just take
yeah knight fd7 is a smart move so he's
um
preparing f5
so now we have to do something for sure
like it's either
knight b5 attacking the pawn or we go a3
before c5
but it's definitely definitely time to
act okay let's start with 95
i actually don't see a comfortable way
for black to defend the d61
maybe he plays something like a6 knight
xd6 queen c7
but then we are happy even after 94. so
it is not about winning the pawn it's
just about uh
eliminating d6 which prevents us from
winning the d5 pawn queen b6
runs into bishop s3 queen a6 runs into
knight c7
so my bet is something like f5 or a6
it's also nice that after knight xd6 we
we're not even uh
too worried about you know wanderings
as a knight and also once because even
some knight xf7 followed by d6
or knight xb7 will always give white
a tremendous compensation
yeah he plays a6 after all so i can also
include bishop d2 here bishop d2 queen
b6 bishop e3
9c5
doesn't bleed anywhere actually okay
then i just think
yeah he plays queen before exactly yes
that's what i'm talking about so now i
guess we just go knight t4
and uh yes he goes upon back but it is
not
as a pawn he really needs okay now i
guess we play b3
and then after queen before my idea is
to play a4
and to follow it up with some [ __ ]
pastry
i think it's just best for plugs to be
honest
his pieces are also randomly placed like
he needs his beat knight to
uh to be on f6 then it would be just
slightly better for white but with
knight on beta think it's
uh i mean objectively it should be
almost over bishop a3
rook d8 okay i guess we just play rook
c1
bringing the pieces slowly
f5 runs into 95 96
and now we also have some strange ideas
like
i don't know 96
our bishop is yeah okay he takes we take
back
bishop h6
so he wants to get f5 and prevents
knight g5
this is smart i
think it's a little bit too late
okay so now i guess uh
once we cannot play knight g5 we play
9d6 right
e4 i think allows knight takes b7
[Music]
and then i just go bishop p2
rook is seven wow this is funny
okay bishop p2 is still there
just want to play it simple like d6
bishop c4 and so on
okay bishop c5 wins in exchange but i
don't even need it probably
okay let's play d6 attacking g8
yeah this is a blunder
okay nice a nice strategy game
all right